intelligence reveals that the true sons
have taken over the national Bond Bank
and are using it as a stronghold to run
their operations from
shd agents must seize this opportunity
to their advances and dismantle
the true Sun's grip on the compound
[Music]
in the Heart of the City agents have
been presented with a critical Mission
their objective to disrupt the network
of true sons who have set up a
stronghold in the National Bond Bank a
fortress that is being used as a hub for
their operations
bursting through the entrance the team
faced a storm of resistance from the
true Sun guards
in a display of their Advanced Training
the agents were able to neutralize the
threat and proceed deeper into the
banking Hall
once the area was Secure the agents
would establish defensive positions
making sure to cover any angle that
could see a counter-attack
when they were satisfied that their
position was under control they shifted
to their primary objective to locate the
true Sun's hidden Armory
navigating through the corridors the
agents remained alert
as they reached the heart of the bank
they discovered the heavily guarded
Armory a trove of deadly weapons and
resources
removing this would certainly hinder any
immediate plans they had and would
likely take months for them to recover
from the loss
with calculated Precision the agents
Unleashed on the stockpiles reducing
them to little more than burning ruins
but their mission was far from over
pushing through the compound it would
come across communication equipment that
was vital in connecting the true Sun's
vast Network
shd agents aware of the significance of
this equipment would go on to dismantle
and destroy it severing the enemy's
ability to coordinate and maintain
control over their forces
it was during this time that they would
receive critical Intel on a true Sun's
leader who happened to be on site
Sergeant Bourne
fighting through the compound it
wouldn't be long before the agents would
catch up to ball
surrounded by a seemingly endless wave
of bodyguards their training was put to
the test
after a long fight through the bank's
hallways they would eventually call a
sergeant ball taking him down before he
was able to escape
with the Hostile presence removed and
their mission concluded the team
regrouped and made their way to the exit
we've installed the lights the cache has
been vacuum sealed we've even set up a
negative air chamber between the vaults
and the rest of the branch
good seems like you've followed the
protocol to the letter thank you and
what about your employees how are they
feeling oh fine
well I've got two tellers that have
called out thick the past three days but
they're not the best workers pretty sure
they're using this outbreak to score a
paid vacation have you sent anyone to do
a wellness check on them no I'll send
someone to check on them gonna need
their names and home addresses Tim
Beatty and Sarah Green addresses should
be in their HR file
I'll get it for you
thanks good work here
in a conversation between the bank
director and the jtf Hazmat specialist
several key points were discussed
regarding the bank's preparedness during
the outbreak
confirming that the necessary
precautions had been taken including the
installation of the lights vacuum
sealing cash and the establishment of a
negative air chamber to separate the
vaults from the rest of the branch The
jtf Specialist acknowledged and approved
of their adherence to protocols that
have been outlined
further cushioning revealed that there
were a couple of Bank employees that
have stopped showing up to work
The jtf Specialist insists that they
need to be checked up on
what about New York the district Union
branch in Brooklyn they started burning
all their cash oh seriously
this is the protocol that's such a waste
yeah well a good opportunity though huh
who's gonna know if we burned four bags
instead of five
two bank tellers discuss what branches
in Brooklyn have been doing burning all
of the cash its precaution to destroy
any potentially infected bills
their reaction to this seeing this is an
opportunity is likely mimicked by a
larger number of others during this time
across multiple other branches
showing that regardless of the
procedures put in place during a time
like this human nature will always be
there to undermine the greater goal
I thought it was a joke it's not a joke
we've got orders from corporate to
quarantine the cash and keep it in the
vault until further notice
do you want me to count it first
no just get that cash out of here
do it as fast as you can and make sure
you're wearing gloves and a mask
how much do you want
ten thousand
twenty thousand but you can use the
money to order more medicine it's a
win-win
how much do you need six months supply
for a family of four
that's not how antibiotics work you
shouldn't be taking them all the time
fine then a hundred doses
how much do you want for a hundred doses
two hundred thousand dollars
I'll have it for you tomorrow
I can meet you at the clinic
give me the drugs and I'll give you the
cash
[Music]
yeah the bank director has emulated the
actions of some of his employees by
using money that was meant to be
destroyed however his motivations differ
from greed
instead he is driven by the need to
prepare for the unfolding events and
Safeguard his family specifically he
seeks to acquire antibiotics for their
well-being
but regardless of motive the damage
being done here is to the same caliber
I've actually really enjoyed playing
through the classified assignments again
some are surprisingly difficult like
most of you I haven't touched them since
the game first came out and I actually
had no idea that so many hadn't played
them at all there are only short
missions with a handful of objectives
but the Intel collected from them gives
a bit more detail around what it was
like before everything went completely
to hell
this particular Mission serves as a
reminder that in the midst of chaotic
circumstances greed continues to be a
driving influence for many this is
partly due to the skepticism that many
people Harbor unless they are directly
witnessing the gravity of the situation
first hand
meanwhile there are individuals driven
by an unwavering determination to
protect their loved ones resorting to
any means necessary even if it
compromises the broader perspective
anyway I hope you've enjoyed this video
thank you very much for watching and
extremist malice extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]